what's up everyone welcome back to the
supper Suite a tiff 2022 for another
interview I feel like you can already
see someone sitting on this couch that
conveys how excited I am about this
interview in this movie the team behind
sick congratulations what a ride my God
thank you thanks so I don't know who
wants to do the honors John or Kevin but
you have to do this because we're at a
festival and not everybody out there
knows what sick is just yet but who
would like to give a brief synopsis if
you're moving John go for it okay sick
is uh from the mind of Kevin Williamson
it is a uh the setup is a rather
familiar kind of archetypal horror setup
of uh two young women in a lake house uh
what makes this one unique is that it's
kind of a a period piece going all the
way back to 2020 uh when we were uh all
experiencing kind of quarantine for the
first time and and it and it is sort of
tapping into the you know in many ways
the mindset of the kind of common
paranoia hysteria but I think that's the
setup of sick is two young women going
to quarantine together in uh Parker's
father's lake house and then uh
obviously things happen at the lake
house and things go sideways things
happen and things don't stop happening
like down for a second we'll get to that
you kind of gave me a good segue for a
question for Kevin because I feel like
we're seeing a lot of pandemic move
movies and a lot of times the response I
hear is it's too soon or it's going to
be dated too quickly so how do you kind
of manage those two things when you jump
into writing a script like this we
actually thought about that when you're
writing it we're like well is this going
to be too soon and then as we were
filming it like oh this is just going to
be we had the same conversation it's
going to be dated and I think it's just
you decide I really think it depends on
on where your mindset is I think the the
movie transcends the pandemic because it
is just such a Thrill Ride and it is a
it is at its core just a fun slasher
film so I think it goes beyond that if
you know so we'll see and we'll see if
they'll let the audience tell us I don't
want to spoil anything but just like for
my own head because I have to know did
you ever play around with the ending and
the motivation
yes we did we played around with it
several times but one of the things that
we wanted to do is we were all sitting
around in the very beginning of the
pandemic just scared and uncertain with
our own lives watching TV all the time
and not knowing what this pandemic was
going to bring or when it was going to
end or how it was going to turn out and
we just thought well what if we put a
face to that fear and that uncertainty
in the form of a man with a knife and
what might that look like and so that's
sort of that's how the whole movie sort
of manifested and from there we sort of
came up with the rest John I'll come
back your way just for the the setup and
like the look of the film and everything
because I was reading that it was
inspired by like 70s and 80s slasher
movies the ones that kind of established
the traditional chase scene so what are
certain things about those Inspirations
that you wanted to uphold but then
what's something that you strove to do
differently to set your movie apart well
I think like you say the setup is is is
is is familiar and and in many ways it
is Remini innocent of movies that I mean
things that Kevin would talk about often
Friday the 13th and movies that were you
know kind of set on a lake back then and
then of course you have some of the
great ones from the 70s like Texas
Chainsaw Massacre and things like that I
I think that
um
my goal through this and I think what we
were trying to do is is bring you into
something that's familiar and then and
then let that as uh serve as a way to
kind of pull you in and let your mind
kind of take you often in the wrong
direction we could kind of subvert your
expectations because that's always the
purpose of it is to try to you know show
you something familiar a dark hallway an
open doorway and then what is going to
be on the other side of it I think Kevin
who's such a
not you know not only someone who's done
so many masterful films in this genre
but he's a true student of the genre and
at this point uh was my professor if you
will because he knows this genre way
better than I do you know I'm a fan of
movies but you know Kevin's specialty
and horror he was really able to say
oftentimes well we've seen that before
or this has been done and this has been
done and in some ways it's it's kind of
embracing that and saying okay this has
been done but maybe we'll do it slightly
this way and we're always kind of
calibrating the expectations of the
audience and I think look wise uh I
think what we try to do is take
a genre that is generally presented
oftentimes in a in a very heightened
kind of uh a heightened sensibility and
we were saying let's kind of bring this
almost down to A unsettling degree of
naturalism where where where the the
killers are very much human and the
struggles between killers and attack and
victims can be very ugly and messy and
almost drawn out fights at times
if you like that mentality makes your
work even harder that idea of it being
grounded and real with all of these
struggles getting I'll start with you
here because we were just talking before
you have done some other genre movies
before but I believe this is the first
like slasher type movie I mean I want to
do everything and the fact that my first
slasher came from the mind of the
slasher King in my book is kind of
insane
um I love that John wanted to keep it
very real and natural like we're like
there was a whole talk about shoes for
example like why would she put shoes on
if if there's a killer in the house you
you you run around Barefoot all night
but um I mean I connected to this film
specifically because
I think one of my worst fears actually
during the pandemic being in a house
with my family all women I would think
about someone breaking in like
everybody's in their houses they're
going crazy you know it's kind of crazy
but
um yeah this was a quite a wild ride but
um and it was it was difficult for sure
but um
I had an incredible time truly that
answer is making me think I want
everyone to answer this I think about
this all the time because clearly I'm
obsessed with her in particular obsessed
with slasher movies if you were in a
slasher movie situation let's say being
chased by Ghostface or something of the
sorts what would be your greatest asset
that would give you a chance to escape
but then also what would be your
greatest weakness that would probably do
you in and let him get you
I'm about to expose myself right now I'm
like so if you want to get me this is
what you have to do
um no I would say probably my greatest
strength is
and I will say this and on behalf of all
women
going around the world as a young woman
your fight or flight is a lot stronger
than you think it is and a lot stronger
than everybody else thinks that it is
and it was something that was so
exciting to figure out also with
somebody that I trusted so much like
coming into this and with John who made
us feel so safe on set and and with
Kevin who's so generous with the
characters that he gave us I feel like
it really felt like a survival movie
from like what what does it look like
when two young women on five five or
under I'm just I'm exaggerating
um five five or under I'm not you know
like five are putting are put in these
circumstances that is acting and as two
young women who grew up in the pandemic
like literally my senior year was cut
short from NYU because because of the
pandemic and to be able to put all of
those feelings of uncertainty that I
hadn't really worked through none of us
had really worked through it but like
working through it on camera was
something that firstly brings you so
much closer to yourself everybody else
on set and also the grander community of
everybody else is going through this but
at the same time it's just badass I'm
like it's about time you find two five
five and under I hope I hope one of
y'all try me y'all saw what I did well
you will well what they did so great
with John and these actresses is is they
don't make one dumb move in the movie
and that was very important to Caitlyn
Crabb who was the co-writer of this
script she was like we have to go
through through this and make sure that
every decision made is the very next
smartest decision in the moment it can
be impulsive it can be erratic but it
has to be the smartest decision in the
moment and they pretty much hold true to
that they go here and then they go here
and then they go to C to D to e and it's
one long extended chase scene but
there's no wrong moves made like you can
support and argue every movement
decision they make in the movie
and I also have to like it's it does it
doesn't seem like it's calculated like
we've been here before it's just it's
just genuinely like okay Parker knows
this house really well this is her best
friend on the whole entire planet she's
gonna do anything to save her and this
happens almost one night it flows so
well and yeah it is they don't make one
dumb move
I don't know if Gideon could pull yeah
she could do it but Parker could very
good definitely can you survive a
slasher movie at this point you know I'm
I'm very defensive so I believe in
defensive sleeping and
defensive Home Alone defensive like you
know I check my claws that I go through
the shower curtain I do it all I'm that
person I've been doing it since I was a
kid and I still do it it is a ritual and
so before you go to bed you just check
the house it's as simple as that okay I
feel like that was like the 101 that
maybe I needed to put my mind I like
when your movies came
um going back to what you two were just
kind of talking about here I'm curious
what is it like making sure that we kind
of feel who these two characters are
when it's such an action-heavy piece is
there anything you could be doing during
the stunt scenes that still conveys to
us who they are and what their
relationship means to each other I can
think of something right away when Mary
fall I'm allowed to give things away
right maybe not like okay okay there's a
moment where something pretty painful
happens to her and I'm in the middle and
I'm in the middle of
a Chase with the Killer and I make sure
to come outside and tell her
to stay in place and that I love her and
you see that tenderness between them
and I think that moment was
I mean it's very stressful but you know
it just shows like you're gonna be okay
I promise you and I'm gonna come back
for you I'm not gonna let anything bad
happen and I think that's what's so like
going off on that it's the relationships
it's entirely the relationships that
both that they talk about like how
comfortable they are it's I feel like
for me what was really important is as
college students the people that you
make as you're becoming an adult are
your chosen family and I feel like that
is a question that we were constantly
like going going like I feel like um
exploring at the same time as me and
Gideon were also getting to know each
other that like in these moments there's
fight or flight for you but there's
fight or flight when your family is
involved yeah and they really are
Parker's sister yeah because of her
history like and they're intelligent
women and so in this moment to
like to have to make sense of your
emotional intelligence also just you're
a pure I'm a human I gotta survive
intelligence at the same time whilst
um having this like high-stakes
situation this clock is ticking this
person can be anywhere it's um I feel
like that is what carries and it's trust
there's a lot of trust it plays also
into the larger responsibility theme
that sort of runs to the film which is
we were trying to sort of talk about
what was happening in the world around
us about should we be wearing masks
should we not what responsibility do we
have to ourselves and to the world
around us and what you see and we we
just put that all down into a
relationship between these two women and
their responsibility to each other to
express the greater theme we haven't
even discussed the fact that this is
your first feature yeah oh my you just
jump into the deep end why don't you is
there anything having gone through the
process that now makes you say I'm so
glad my first was on that set with those
people in this genre
all day baby that's all I'm gonna say I
I'm so grateful to say that this is like
my first set family because I feel like
I didn't know what I was getting into
and for me I I take my work very
seriously and to be given this
opportunity I did not take lightly but
on top of that I am never gonna get my
college years back I am never going to
be able to it felt like that that
important to me when you read the script
it's not just a slasher this is real
life we all went through that communal
trauma and to be like wow I get to make
art about this also with people that I
trust and that I look up to that I've
always looked up to is like
I mean an opportunity of a lifetime and
it's also 30 days of like night shoots
and baby you don't get funnier than when
you are up for 30 days in a row and I
don't think any laughs as much as they
do than when they're on a slasher yeah
like there's a lot of Giggles for both
of you the first slasher movie what
advice would you give or what tip or
trick would you give to another actor
about to jump into their first like
Chase driven slasher movie what I don't
what would you what stretch probably
yeah
and just commit they are so committed to
what they're going through in this film
it's so it's just so real and authentic
I mean like for your for I keep
forgetting it was your first yeah it was
incredible that is a great point is that
I mean I think that's why we cast these
people is because for something like
this the the the fear that the audience
is going to feel is directly related to
what they're presenting and they you
know they have to do it take after take
after take and sell the Peril of this
and they're not playing superheroes or
playing real people so they have to play
this in a very vulnerable way and they
have have to be sometimes just breaking
down and crying because you're so afraid
and then mustering the strength and all
of that and they never shied away from
just going 100 every time and that's
that's what you need to sell this and I
and I think in one point and about this
project in my mind and What attracted me
to it is that in many ways I feel like
it's actually a thriller masquerading as
a slasher movie in the sense that it is
it it the setup is very much slasher
movie but
um traditional slasher movies have kind
of an opening like our film and then and
then it goes into one by one people are
getting knocked off and no one is really
aware of it until the third act what was
clever to me about what was on the on
the page and this is that this is just
two people away in a house and very soon
they're wise to what's going on and we
are now launched into kind of almost a a
seemingly real time just fight for their
lives chase that in many ways the film
Skips a second act and goes right into
the third act and to me that's why it's
a thriller because a thriller really
depends on you imagining horrible things
and waiting to see what if that horrible
thing happens and this movie keeps you
imagining what's a horrible thing I mean
there's these two wonderful people and
hopefully you don't want either of them
to perish but if you've watched enough
of these you assume one of them's going
to so who's it going to be and that kind
of pulls you through the movie so I I
felt like that was one of the clever
ideas from the get-go that I love that
you can just get launched into this
chase that goes on and on and it's way
more intimate because it's such a small
cast because there aren't so many people
and I feel like there usually is a huge
there's a large amount of people in a
slasher film and this is totally
different and there's a lot of trust
between them but the adrenaline that you
feel while you're filming it like you're
in it you're there it's happening to you
um yeah I would also say like I feel
like matching the energy of your other
um cast members and the the
circumstances that you're given is
really important in terms of like going
there it's and also like I feel like we
were also very lucky in the sense that
there are very real circumstances that
we were quite literally just come out of
and so there was a lot of
unpacking that we had to do just in
general with the movie that we were able
to do again like on screen so I would
say just for any actor take care of
yourself when you're not there like
really like Let Yourself Go and relax
but when you're there like that that is
where your heart and focus should be and
honestly just have fun doing a slasher
is the best for the funnest thing ever
it's the best form of therapy
I have to let you guys go and it's
breaking my heart right now but you know
what I'm doing now I need to ask you a
scream question I feel like I could have
like a mile long list and keep you here
all day but one of the ones that I
really want to know your take on is
whenever it comes to like the most
iconic slasher franchises I feel like
people often roll their eyes when they
continue on and on and on however
because scream evolves as the genre in
general evolves it makes me think that
it could go on and on forever is that
how you feel about the franchise's
future
I yes at first I thought maybe I I might
have thought the opposite of that but
now since I've been proven wrong
repeatedly and this last scream was such
a pleasure I think one of the one of the
wonderful things about scream is there's
a different killer in every film whereas
we in most you know Halloween and Friday
there's Jason there's Michael there's
Freddy they don't go away and we
actually ghost face changes with every
movie and so we have an opportunity to
change the motive and change the story
and we can always twist and turn it and
it's set up to be sort of this uh it was
meant to be sort of a a game changer all
along so the trick is how do we keep
game changing and I think um this new
team that I'm working with are awesome
they're absolutely amazing they're
wonderful human beings they're talented
and it's just been a pleasure to be a
part of this new regime
so one of the ways you game change is
you put ghost space in a big city the
thought of what could happen when you do
that is blowing my mind space Takes
Manhattan oh no I mean if they call them
the movie that I would legit watch it I
like Jason Takes man I think there's uh
there's a joke in there okay I would
hope so I have to let you go huge
congratulations on sick and thank you
for being here today to everybody out
there keep an eye out for the movie and
stay tuned for more Tiff 2022 interviews
coming your way very soon